What just happened to the game?
It was just up?
What just happened?
I switched scenes and it literally just went...
It went...it went...out of existence
Hold on, let me get it back up.
That was so weird That was weird.
It is also kind of a bizarre game because if I...
No!
It's not a hot dog moment!
Ashes!
No!
A huanting.
It's a Russian huant This game is kind of strange because when you have it open, you can't...
You know how like if you're trying to get out of a game, you can hit like the windows key?
It...it doesn't let you Once you're in the game, you're stuck in the game Alt-Tab.
I never tried that I always forget that's a feature Only naughty people do that feature because they're like I gotta switch real fast Only naughty people do that Alt-Tab.
I have no fear OK, Indiana Jones.
Play Let's...hopefully it...
The title does not appear to quit properly the last time it ran Do you want to run...there is a safe mode?
No
OK, OBS
It quit again?
Oh my god
I'm gonna become the Joker.
Why is it that I always have a tech issue?
No way.
I'm going to become the Joker I paid
extra $30.
Even though the game is on Game Pass, I paid the $30 To get the DLC With the open T-shirt Joker
Oh sorry It will change your video settings, but not your controls You know what?
Let's just say yes.
I'm gonna run it in safe mode Don't run it!
It changed my settings too much I can't get out of the game
I'm stuck in the game!
And I can't change the resolution.
Hold on Hold on.
I have to wait through all of this.
I have to wait through all of this I think Oh my gosh
This is...this is different No, no, wait.
It's giving me a different screen But before it showed Indiana Jones standing here What is going on?
What is going on?
Why is everything haunted?
I'm supposed to be the ghost I didn't have this main menu.
Neither did I!
Neither did I.
OK, ALT TAB Which is...oh I think that was my...
Oh thank goodness.
OK it worked I think that was my controller.
Pretty sure this is a controller game.
OK Let's just adjust this here like so How are you the way that you are?
It's not me!
Classic Todd Howard I've never seen this menu.
I opened this game up like three times today you guys Never had an issue.
Maybe this is the...
Oh, controller.
Maybe this is the low safe mode This is the safe mode maybe No, this is not a hot dog moment The title screen changes depending on where you are in the game.
Not chapter wise, but literally where you ended last session I ended...nowhere Well, anyway.
This is a cold dog moment.
Anyway Well, hopefully this works.
Hopefully it still looks good And everything.
I'm nervous.
I made some changes, but hopefully it all works Anyway Anyway
Hi Mint.
Hi Chat.
First time here.
Hello!
Sorry you came at such a craziness time Time to whip all the bad guys Let's see the options.
Tutorial on Oh yeah, you guys.
Great circle Traveling suit.
What is this smirk he has?
But, but, but this is what I paid the money for
And then you can get the bullwhip or you can get the lion tamer Let's do the bullwhip.
I like it better Arigato!
Arigato!
Chuu!
I hope we still get Minto being down bad for India.
Stop!
Fortune and glory indeed
You're gonna die going after your fortune and glory What if they called him Freaky Anna Jones and he had a freaky smile and whip people I'm not gonna lie.
The smirk is a little much here It's kind of wild OK.
I'll just have the controller as it is for now What?
No!
This makes no sense
20x1080.
I think that's wrong I think that's not correct I don't think that's correct But it's fine.
It is what it is.
It's fine I did... OK.
You guys, I did change this Because... You know what?
The FPS limit...
Was at 1000!
It was all the way up!
Yeah, she's always like this.
Stop!
Who needs 1000 FPS?
So I changed it earlier.
I was just like that's insanity I feel like 120.
You know, I could do 60.
It really doesn't matter, but...
120 2000 is better.
We're gaming.
I'm downloading more FPS Indiana Jones maid cafe They serve you, like, your meal They like... They serve it on a whip And it goes to your table Like that Watching shirtless.
So when I hear Indy, where is your shirt?
This is levels of parasocial that are beyond...
Are you a fan of the movies Mint?
I am!
I love Indiana Jones!
I've been so excited for this game I'm ready!
I'm so ready to play Indiana Jones!
Oh my gosh, I'm so excited And I'm so glad because I was really excited for the game and a lot of people were like...
I don't know, Minto.
I'm not so excited for it.
I have low expectations That's what everybody with a low expectation sounds like And then it got all the good reviews!
And I was like...
I'm so excited.
I love Indiana Jones.
It's like my favorite movie series And Top Gun But Top Gun is not really... I guess it's two movies.
I guess it's like...
Not a series though.
It's a little less, right?
Watch Along?
I actually just did an Indiana Jones Watch Along like Friday It was a members.
It was for members, but...
Time for Minky Anna Phantoms and her unsay so...moans?
This is really good graphics for an indie game Raymac thanks for the 5 gifted and Murphy thanks for the 10 gifted Ducky thanks for the 10 gifted.
You guys are so silly.
Anytime I ever mention memberships you are like...
Time to gift.
My moans?
Maybe my groans?
Because I'm like... That's your jokes Not that fond of indie, but here for Mint.
Also nice hat.
Thanks.
You will be a fan of indie maybe Alvin thanks for the 5 gifted.
Raymac thanks for the 5 gifted.
Ducky thanks for the 5 gifted And I can't scroll back, but whoever came back to membership, thank you Pyrobuck thanks for the 10 gifted.
What movie do you like the most?
Out of Indiana Jones?
Maybe Covenant of the Ark Though I've seen Temple of Doom most.
Last Crusade.
Last Crusade is really great Last Crusade.
The first and the third movie are tied probably Elquesa.
Thank you for the 5 gifted.
Thank you Thank you, thank you.
Last Crusade for you Sirstreak thanks for the 5 gifted.
Crystal Skull.
Oh yeah Temple of Doom guy.
Temple of Doom is great.
They are all great
I like... I like all of them 1, 3, 2.
I think 2 is definitely the... like the...
Gale thanks for the 5 gifted.
I think 2 is definitely like the weakest out of the 3 But it is not bad by any means.
It's just the weakest, you know
The movie is called Raiders of the Lost Ark.
Excuse me?
Fake fan How dare you say that you like Indiana Jones and yet you say the Ark and the Covenant
Raiders!
Oh my gosh!
Oh my gosh we have actual Raiders.
Thank you Kenja for the raid.
Thank you Oh my gosh.
If you know how like on Twitch you can have raid sounds or whatever Rock Baraba thanks for the 5 gifted
Hello everybody who is joining.
If you don't know who I am, my name is Mint Phantom And I'm a ghost made Vtuber and I love Indiana Jones.
Thank you CF2, thanks for the gifted Nexy thanks for the 5 gifted.
Okay bye thanks for the 5 gifted I really didn't like the newest one.
What?
I've talked about it the other day but...
Chica thanks for the gifted.
Spark thanks for the 5 gifted
Yeah, Raijin thanks for the 5 gifted
I don't remember what I was saying.
It's just thanks for the 5 gifted Wish I worked on Steam Deck.
It doesn't?
Is it too beefy?
KZ Raijin thanks for the gifted There was the newest movie called Dial of Destiny Which like... I wish also there was like some ambiance or something on this title screen Okay, it's like mixed reviews but I don't think it's nearly as bad as the Crystal Skull In fact I kind of liked how wacky they went with it But I've said this before.
If you know Metal Gear and you know Metal Gear Solid 4 Then that is basically what that movie is.
Missing Link thanks for the 5 gifted.
Thank you Dial of Destiny was so crazy.
It's actually so crazy But I kind of liked it.
I didn't mind it.
It was better than Crystal Skull It's funny because like... I love Crystal Skull.
It's very campy It's funny because I think people like forget how some aspects of Indiana Jones is You know like they were just like...
This doesn't really make sense that they would do this for Indiana Jones And I'm like... Indiana Jones has been supernatural from the very beginning Indiana Jones has been kind of crazy from the very beginning It's funny They're just like what?
I'm not going to spoil Dial of Destiny but they're just like what?
You would do that for Dial of Destiny?
That's so weird It's just like well... It's Indiana Jones It's Indiana Jones.
Supernatural Was Supernatural the main criticism of that movie?
I think people did not like where it went.
But I liked it And also... But I don't think it's... Like I said, I don't think it doesn't have it's criticisms Sorry, I just... I already... I talked about this like 3 days ago because of the watchalong So I feel like I'm repeating myself.
So if you watched the watchalong and watched me rant about this Sorry if you're having to listen to me talk about it again
But...
Isn't it science fiction in Crystal Skull?
I guess if you consider... I guess...
What?
Aliens are... Aliens can kind of be supernatural, right?
But you know, it really depends on what your definition of supernatural is, you know?
If you're like sci-fi or supernatural
You know?
They found the Holy Grail.
There was a man living there for 700 years Indiana Jones has always been a little wacky But we love it that way I wasn't opposed to the aliens.
The movie was just bad You know what?
That's fair enough That is fair enough.
I remember watching it... I think I only watched it once And I was like, you know what?
Once is enough for me I only watched one indie movie and it was Dial of Destiny so this main menu image is already peak cinema You have to watch the others I swear, Dial of Destiny is just MGS4 And honestly, it has... I feel like it's also same split between people as MGS4 So,
it's the best comparison Let's start the game everybody.
I'm so excited Peru Oh, this must be where it tried to start me at Except...
Yes, because I picked some of these, right?
Is that supposed to be Indiana right there?
No, OK.
I see.
That's a bad guy We're knocking the gun out of his hand I picked moderate before, but you can pick hard and very hard Whichever you choose But I picked moderate And then I picked moderate for the puzzles
Oh my god, I'm Indiana Jones
I'm him!
Oh no Hold on Hold on, hold on I turned off...
I turned off motion blur earlier I think it turned it back on Let's see Motion blur It's also...
Motion blur off OK Chromatic aberration off Do I need the sharpening?
Probably not
Let's make it a little less crisp Film grain, OK Depth of field Depth of field which creates a sense of depth by blurring objects that are out of focus Turn off the film grain Where?
Oh, there it is I guess we don't need it
Depth of field I'm gonna turn that off too Maybe
Let's see how it looks OK, back
Why does it look the way that it does?
Why is my head bobbing like that?
Oh my god OK, Andy, I'm not gonna get motion sick from this game Oh my god, the FPS is so...
No!
No way Is my computer not beefy enough?
Mito, why it runs so well on mine?
Yeah, are you also streaming?
Do you also have OBS and VTube Studio and VBridger all turned on?
I don't think so!
OK?
Does it look good on OBS?
Can I see my body?
My body.
How do I punch?
Oh, I'm in combat mode
OK, let's jump OK, let's just keep walking Whip it, baby.
Whip it good
What do you want?
What do you want from me, sir?
He's like, why are you so slow?
Oh my goodness.
Oh gosh I don't know Oh, here It's my turn X Oh, X Sorry, I'm not in PlayStation
It's like the movie
It's just like the movie
Wait, are those guys from the movie?
Is that guy on the right...oh my gosh Is that guy...
Is this guy going to betray us?
Relax
Is there a way to run?
OK, I just hold down faster I'm running.
I'm speedrunning this game right now Where do I go?
Oh my god, oh my god Indiana Jones and the Great Frame Drop Everybody who convinced me out of getting a new graphics card I hope you are really enjoying this
Let's see.
I wonder if there is some stuff we can turn on or turn down Let's see, let's see, let's see It's only...it's not even on ultra.
Everything is on high I don't want to turn it down to medium.
It will be so ugly Try 60 FPS.
You know what?
That's a good idea too Even though I feel 120 is that sweet spot, but...
OK, manual
Oh my god, what are you saying?
Or 30 FPS.
No!
Cinematic 24
Stream is only 60 anyway.
You know what?
That's so true.
I never think about that But what about my experience?
You guys don't want the best for me?
What about my experience?
I'm the one having to look at it To the 120.
You don't care about me?
No, don't say that Let's see Note requires a game restart.
OK, we are not going to touch that.
Let's do the shadow Quality
Reflections off
Motion blur.
But we have no motion blur.
I don't think it will make a difference Hair quality.
That's important
Hair quality.
What's RT?
What is that?
I didn't see it What are you guys seeing?
That I'm not seeing.
What are you guys seeing?
Try turning off ray tracing.
Where is it?
I don't even see it Am I blind?
The advanced settings.
Did I miss it?
I don't see it Go down
It's off.
Oh, sun shadows It's off, you guys I got one guide.
You guys, it's literally off You need to learn how to read If you haven't updated GPU drivers yet, it might be worth doing so I have recently actually Crabby, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Lamby, thanks for the gift.
Let's see how it is now Oh, it looks like doodoo, but that's OK It looks like an old game Is this ours?
There's a Bucky!
Oh my God
Warriors of the Clouds My journey through the ruins of the Chapoyan culture It's mine now Take their food
Oh boy.
It looks better though
I see ruins Yeah baby!
Where am I going?
What's this?
X It's just like the movie Three Days, Poison
Oh my God, it's just like the movie for real
Three Days!
Have you heard We Will Rock You, Meg and the Stallion?
I haven't
This is an original story, right?
It's not just the movie, huh?
Drink up Indy This guy, his eyes are bugging
Yummy Which way should we go?
Left or right?
No, no, no.
I decide, I decide I hate this guy.
I'm going right
You won't catch me following your pathways
Press A to vault
Nice What's this?
Oh, another place
I'm lifting the tree He's so bloodied Minto has Indy scared by Minky off bucket list
South America, 1936 We look really messed up
Do you want to play a social media game with us?
I'm playing another game.
I'm playing Indiana Jones
Computer, good luck!
Nice slideshow
Guys, I might...
I might become a PNG This guy I wonder if I should become a PNG I suddenly have health
I'm gonna try it.
Hold on Oh, how do I... OK, I'll tab Goodbye!
I'm dead!
Hold on.
OK, now...
I have to get a PNG of me Hold on.
I'll get a real cute one, OK?
I'll get a real cute one Here we go
Sorry, I have a potato PC.
Sorry that Indiana Jones is so beefy I'm so sorry So sorry
Back to our regularly scheduled programming
Oh my gosh, look!
You guys, look at the difference!
Oh my gosh, it's like we are playing an actual game now Oh, it's so smooth
We gotta take this out.
We gotta take this out Oh my gosh, look at him Senor...
Please,
Senor Oh my gosh, it looks so good now Sorry, I'm so beefy, you guys Sorry that I'm just like... You know, they don't call me Boomer for nothing I'm, you know...
Do I not have my own torch?
Oh my gosh, this is so awesome!
We are in the cave!
It doesn't look as nasty as it does in the movie though Connecting to the ghost dimension takes a lot of power.
Of course it does, you know
That's messed up Guys, that's messed up.
We know what comes from there That's so...look at it The hole Hey buddy, you alright?
He's looking at me Be careful.
Oh my gosh, he's going ghost!
What the hell?
Why were you looking up?
Catch a quick distance Oh god, he's going ghost again!
What's this?
X Clearing the path everybody.
We are clearing the path
The VA for Indy is Troy Baker of Revolver Ocelot.
I know!
Wow, I see!
Thank you for the super chat
Is this like a mini game?
Oh my god!
Do I actually swipe them off?
Oh my god, I get to remove the spiders!
Oh, I thought I did one at a time It's so funny Wow, he looks so good.
Yeah, I was very excited to know that Troy Baker, because now I'm just...
Oh my god, I could just hear...If it had a bit more of a fake southern accent, then it would be Revolver Ocelot Touch light
Oh my gosh, I can't believe this is just the movie How long has he been dead for?
He was.
Reset the trap Oh, we are resetting it.
Foreshadowing We are fine
Too far to jump.
How do you know?
You crouched, right buddy?
Oh, I can RB
Here we go!
Oh, I did it.
It wasn't nearly as crazy as I thought it was going to be
He still grabs it by the pants here Oh my god
Yeah, we'll leave our whip here
And he looks so cool Oh, it's the ugly idol
Yo buddy
How would you know?
How would you know that there is nothing to fear?
Has anyone ever been here?
You don't know
Push Push
So I go to this one too?
Push Push Oh, we are being really sneaky Push I like this That's it How cool!
Ok, then this one.
Push I'm too good at this game
Ok Push
Yep, I did it, I think
Oh no, I didn't.
I didn't finish it.
Ok, there is more Push
Are we good?
The music is scaring me
Ok, alright.
Slowly, easy now Easy Oh my god, no way
Ok, maybe that's enough
Ok, if I did a good job then it won't activate You know?
Oh no!
I failed the tutorial
Andy!
Andy no!
Oh my god The whip!
Give me the whip!
Press...hold LT Ok!
RT!
I'm holding...
Oh, there we go.
Ok.
Sorry, I was doing RB Give me the whip!
L and...
I don't think I was going to make that I don't think I was...
I did not get enough speed there for sure Andy, I don't think this is the time to be smiling buddy Andy!
It looks like you fell half way through.
It really did Go Andy!
Go, go, go!
Get that!
It's important.
His hair is so...neat
Dummy.
El Bozo.
Give me the idol And time to leave See ya, stupid
Press to sprint Wait, who?
Oh, Marion!
Marion was talking
I think we died
Marcus?
Oh my god!
It's Marcus Brody!
No way!
He's in the game!
This guy is so silly
Oh my gosh, a Brody She clapped.
I clapped when I saw it!
What are they doing drinking in my office anyway?
Go home.
Don't you have a family?
Marshall College, Connecticut, USA, 1937 It broke new ground.
Why is it suddenly a horror film?
What?
Everywhere?
Hold on.
We got an apple.
Probably from our students Is Marcus in here?
Dr. Brody!
This guy is out Is there anything we can see while we are in here?
Doesn't seem to be the case Endless trash!
I'm glad we have some red letter media enjoyers here Oh they are making a mess of the place!
I don't think so I think it's the ghost of Abraham Lincoln
I hear sounds.
I'm scared
Oh my god.
What's the point of knocking over the flyers?
Oh my god!
How did they...why?
I'm jumping around.
What?
Oh my gosh
I need my whip I'm scared
I'm scared
Oh we have Bigfoot going on here
Bigfoot The chess club meets your talent
This is fun.
I like the stuff in here I hear something Current exhibitions.
The afterlife and art and archeology Egyptology and archeology wing Anomalia and man
Guys this is freaky I'm crouched
What's going on down there?
Do you guys hear all the sounds?
Unintelligible Latin
Minkeana Jones.
These residents.
They're evil Birds!
Wow!
What's in here?
Oh my gosh!
Look at the horseshoe crab!
He's so cute!
I'm surprised there wasn't like a shadow of a person standing there I don't think these are kids I don't think there's going to be speaking in Latin in the creepy way Oh what's this?
A card Faculty card.
Oh that's me!
What the hell is it doing here?
The break-in Dr. Henry Jones Jr. Professor of archeology, Woolley Hall 15 adventure points Is that like a person down there?
Oh yeah I see their arms.
Their arms are out Why is this so scary?
What's this?
Oh it's a map.
Nice Map unlocked Campus overview.
Where are we?
The map guides you to your next objective Wait.
Close it Like that?
OK Anything else we got around here?
My adventure points
The dance There's so much detail I'm scared you guys.
I'm going to crouch because I'm scared
Why'd you trash the whole place just to speak in Latin in the other room?
Oh He's like growling Oh yeah baby Temple of Doom
OK guys, here we go Here we go Temple of Coom
Sir, I think you need to go home
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
He's huge
He doesn't like tall people apparently If you're too tall you're gonna...
Oh!
OK
Where are my glasses?
I can't see without my glasses Mr. X
I'm getting injured.
Do I have only 3 injury points?
Holy shit!
This is a museum It belongs in a museum When she actually tries to fight the average wisp Oh!
I'm getting choked out!
Sorry
The small man never shuts up Everybody is small to you Mr. X is like...
And you're just in the great circle.
Off to a great start
Salty cat!
Thank you for the 5 gifted
Oh god!
Not the salt.
Have you guys ever smelled the activating salts?
The giant He's too tall to be in a museum
Oh my gosh!
Mr. Brody also sounds so much like him in the movies too He was bald!
Yeah, also bald
Indy...Indy's face sometimes...
Sometimes is a little off But he sounds...Troy Baker does such a great impression.
It's so good What did this guy see?
Oh!
Ok, what do I do with that?
Bastet as a lioness
Ok, anyway.
I don't need this ancient Egyptian stuff.
What's this?
Oh my god!
It's one of those like...
You know how they'll be like...
You know how like...
You know how they'll be like oh yeah look at this figure from ancient times and it looks exactly like an anime girl That's just this baby
Indiana Jones!
Sir!
Are you not the one who is just like...
Are you not the one who is so like oh I must be careful with these items It belongs in a museum
It's a duck Can you give us this cute PNG?
Thank you.
Actually I can't because I use this for standees And promotional items so...
Honestly the fact that I'm using it, you're lucky Funerary mask
Who's that ugly sap?
You're dead.
Ok, what do you steal?
Let's see Screenshot it.
Stop!
No!
This is an ancient bed.
Oh fragment of a wall Let's see.
I'm so sorry I have to be a PNG you guys, but at least it's working now.
At least the game looks good We can actually read these which is kind of crazy Oh sorry, I didn't mean to go...Oh I'm shoving.
Look how hairy my fists are!
Wow!
I'm fighting demons.
Brody!
Brody I'm fighting demons!
Oh I have...That's my stamina down there.
Ok There's a figure from ancient times in the bottom right corner Yeah
I used to collect these jars Like obviously not the real ones, but like when I went through my Egyptian phase I had these jars I'd be like this one has brains.
This one has liver.
I don't know.
Whatever they put in there The manual contains game instructions.
Thanks
Are we not going to figure out what he took?
Oh news article
Who's brains?
They were brains
I'm so old I belong in a museum for old memes You had an Egyptian phase?
I did!
Come here!
What you doing Brody?
Look how cute he is
Oh grandpa.
Oh Brody
There was nothing else in here right?
So he didn't take anything in here.
He was just...
He was just speaking Latin in here for no reason.
Right here The Egyptians didn't put brains into canopic jars.
Instead threw them away thinking that the brain wasn't important Oh really?
I mean I guess if I were to see a brain I'd be like...
Yeah that's not worth it Mint's brain certainly isn't.
Hey!
I can still read your comments you know What's up with this?
Open.
Bandage Can I use it?
Oh equip bandage.
RT
Where did I apply that?
Whatever works.
Take everything.
Take every stock?
I think I need it more than they do Ok there's more stuff over here.
This guy just trashed everything What did he take?
Right here?
I thought I heard footsteps up here This is not my office.
This is my office?
Oh my gosh!
It's the Apple!
Apple!
This is his classroom!
Wow!
This is where that one freaky girl sits with the I love you on her Wow!
Oh my gosh it's like we are in the movie Is there anything on the desk?
I'm an adventurer Shirley's letter.
Oh no
Private tuition.
In the hope that you could go through it again with me.
Love Shirley He says... Oh there's another letter.
Bjorkman's letter?
Is that how you say that?
Dear Professor Jones.
Oh my dear Professor Jones I want to thank you humbly for sending me your letter Stop it.
What do you mean stop it?
It's Shirley not me Your findings undoubtedly pique my interest and I'm glad that you are eager to help us retrieve the Upsala Scroll Of course many years have now passed since we lost ownership of it but I have reason to believe that an ancient and very dangerous cult is behind the theft from Mr. Lawrence There are rumors that one of its members owns an old castle west of Sigtuna If you have the time and opportunity,
you are most welcome to join me so that we can try and find the Upsala Scroll together I can arrange accommodations for you and your potential companions at the centrally located St. Persgatan 10 here in Upsala Wow!
Vivas!
Thank you for everything from a guy who usually only watches clips You should do a quote stream?
To compare what?
Thank you so much for that Kasupa!
Thank you!
Bjork in it What?
Shirley you can't be serious.
I am serious.
Don't call me Shirley
You will get to marry your soulmate I am... I'm a ghost
Anyway There is even more!
Cat mummy notes.
No!
Beautifully crafted cat mummy Odd piece discovered in an unmarked tomb in the Mountain of the Dead Characteristics of craftsmanship usually found in tombs of wealthy people Unusually light... lightweight.
X-ray?
There is something odd about this cat mummy.
I can't put my finger on it That's where I put those notes.
About the cat mummy Duh!
That's what we are all talking about.
The cat mummy
So much lore.
I know right?
I'm becoming such an adventurer Oh wait.
So our office is back this way Is this it?
Faculty lounge.
No.
Down this way Down here.
This is my office
Where is my office?
Is this it?
Why Minto2D?
Game too beefy for me Oh a comic book!
Stranger Yards.
The thrilling adventures of Joe the Archeologist Joe!
With only a throw net and his trusty slingshot he explores the wild corners of the earth
Nerds.
All of them.
Why can't they pay attention to their books?
First rule of Rock Club.
We don't talk about Rock Club Do you think the various figurines will be displayed in jars?
Theoretical... Do you think there is going to be a VTuber museum?
We are still trying to find what this guy took We got beat up and we have nothing.
No information Caution.
Wet floor What if they wanted the bust of Thomas Jefferson?
This guy knows a secret
Sorry I have to be a PNJ Maybe I should be looking in here
It would be a place that is broken into, right?
Oh this one!
There is some stuff here stolen.
Wait, do I need to put the stuff back you think?
The things I threw on the ground?
Oh maybe.
And then we'll know...
Hi Dr. Brody!
Oh press X to place artifacts
Yeah dummies.
Oh, I'm stupid I was wrong, ok Where does it go then?
What was the description of it?
Egyptian goddess.
Oh my gosh, there are so many places
So wait Throw cat.
What's this one?
From... Oh, Babylonian terracotta.
How am I supposed to know where it came from though?
Wait, Babylonian... Oh gosh, you guys, I don't know history.
I don't know geography or history And I don't know flags either
Iraq, so maybe this one?
Ok, cool PNJ Mint is not much flatter than 3D Mint I hope you can get your life today.
This is messed up.
What was this one?
Syria.
Oh gosh
Didn't he say...
What did he say about that?
Oh gosh, you guys.
What's this one?
No?
This one
Ok Is it this one?
This game is making me feel stupider than I already am Oh man, where is it called then?
Try wearing it Wait,
did I try this one?
Oh yeah I'm silly
You think... Oh, this one would make sense here, right?
Because there's the other statues
Yes And then this is...
This one It said Syria.
Where is... Oh, I forgot that this one was free Oh, that's the thing he stole
The lettering, Minto.
You're right Oh,
it's a good thing we got the cat mummy notes Why did he take the cat mummy?
And we got the notes for the cat mummy Puzzle completed Oh, so if I had done the easy...
Yeah Let's keep looking Objective Wait Press and view the map to see the next objective Investigate the theft
Astute deduction, Dr. Brody We shall go investigate Let's go Why don't you know the entire history of Mesopotamia and the ancient Near East?
Oh god Because my AP history class was too cold It was too cold, I couldn't pay attention I think I still passed the exam though And then I became a Vtuber and forgot everything in my brain
Me and my friend would always complain, we'd be like god this classroom is freezing And he would yell at us when we brought in our blankets That's a classroom Where is our...
I can't...
Is it this?
No The window I'm lost Right here Down there?
You mean this one This window I guess this is kind of by our...
Office Nice We are investigating guys Why is it so absolutely wet?
It's so...wow
There is a thing there How do I get that?
It was raining?
Yeah, but like...
This looks a little dramatic, don't you think?
Can I lift this?
Ok
Then we'll climb this like a ladder
Press A to grab and jump ledges.
L to climb Nice Oh my god, the janitor.
Did you see anything?
I can't believe we are just calling this guy a giant What?
Moonwalking?
Look at the way he walks
Ok, but hold on Whoa!
Temple map Temple of the Forbidden Eye Look not into the eyes of Mara and you shall gain admission to the temple of your greatest secret desire Shut up Brody!
Beware the false pathways that lead to death.
Beware the deadly booby traps that lurk within
Is...
Wait a second This isn't the Disney ride, is it?
Oh my gosh Is this the...because the lasers from the eyes...
Is this the ride?
No!
Why?
Because there is the giant snake and then there is the...
Shut up Brody!
I'm nerding out here please How do I punch you?
Oh that's not what I meant to do.
So sorry Oh my god Brody we are not like that You are like my dad
The music is so awesome
How often does this guy, like, does this guy abandon his school?
Is that from Marion?
Cairo?
Marion?
I'm working on it.
Oh my gosh, it is!
For your next adventure.
Oh, it doesn't say.
This guy.
Come on.
What the hell, Indy?
Oh, I'm packing.
Only the essentials.
Okay, we gotta pack, you guys.
We need our gramophone record.
Into the thing.
Wait, so it said this and then... Oh, RB.
For our journal.
Okay.
Notes 7 out of 10.
Oh, we are missing a couple notes.
Should we go find them?
Our Bullwhip.
Siwa.
RT to inspect non-combat items.
Oh.
Oh, sorry Brody.
I didn't... I wasn't trying to punch you.
I'm trying to inspect you, my friend.
Oh, I'm so sorry Brody.
It's just when I let go of the trigger, I can't control myself.
I have a mean streak.
Oh, this is that guy's journal or the book that we got from the players.
Okay, we don't need that, I guess.
So, wait.
Our journal.
We need...
We need three more notes.
I'm gonna go look around just briefly.
Just a little briefly to see if we can grab them real quick.
I'm liking the lore and stuff that we're finding, you know, because it's like...
It's fun to see, you know, like the nod to the rod and things like that.
That's cute.
Didn't know that your violent meant, I'm a ghost.
It's in my nature.
Let's see if we can find it.
I wish I could run faster.
Oh.
Cool.
Let's see.
We're sprinting, we're sprinting.
Indy, I know you're in better shape than this.
I know you are in better shape than this.
Come on.
Don't go acting like you're out of breath.
Come on, man.
This is the... Okay.
And I did... This place confuses me, the layout.
Part time.
Okay, yeah.
I think we got everything in here.
Maybe I won't find it.
If I don't find it, no biggie.
Indy had a little too many cheeseburgers.
Indy, I know... Indy, you can literally... You can take the punch from a giant.
I know that you can run...
More than...
More than two feet?
Indiana Jones.
You're losing your touch, buddy.
I love this collection of rocks.
Just a bunch of rocks.
Maybe there... Maybe we...
I don't know where else to look.
Do you guys know?
Like the outlets in the wall.
Look on his desk.
Okay.
I'll just circle around...
My bad.
We went in here.
There was a newspaper clipping.
Anything else though?
Doesn't seem to be.
Your streams have been making my days better lately while I've been stressed.
Oh no, ma'am!
I'm sorry, you're stressed!
I'm too scared to listen to you read this.
No!
Don't leave!
Punch in the direction of the head.
Or punch in the head...
Wait, huh?
You can't run because it's a school.
Oh, what's this?
This is my song!
Someone's gonna come back and they're gonna be like, this place...
Haunted.
The radio is on.
It's completely destroyed.
Haunted.
Alright.
I think I got everything on here too.
Let's go check his desk.
There's the pendant.
I don't see any notes or anything though.
Where the hell could they be?
What is this?
A necessary addition to the game.
Ha!
Why do you keep holding on to the door?
Is it because you're bracing yourself or when I accidentally punch you?
And what else did we need?
Um, cat mummy photograph.
Where is that?
Oh here.
It's kinda freaky.
Okay.
Alright.
What do you mean a foolhardy escapade?
What do you mean by that?
You were not there.
You were knocked out from the liquor you were drinking Mr. Brody.
Ah!
Your fortune and glory.
Yeah.
Why not?
Midterms.
We're married to our work Mr. Brody.
Oh my god the music is even the same.
From the movies.
I'm going to get the pizza.
Oh spaghetti Mr.
Brody.
Oh he's so cute!
Mama mia says Mr. Brody.
What a strange map.
Oh there we go!
Woo!
Stop.
Don't stop the plane.
He'll die.
Stop.
Map transition.
So great.
Look at the kitty!
Castel Santangelo.
We're all roughed up again.
This is too much.
The fortress.
Oh new adventure.
Oh no it's fascist.
Do I have to be sneaky?
Maybe he can't tell that I'm here.
Sneaking mission?
Don't worry about it.
Do you think he's asleep?
Oh shoot!
I can parry?
Oh!
Oh I'm whipping
him?
Stay down!
He's not talking to me, right?
Ok.
Anyway.
Cool.
How long do you think he'll be down for?
A while, right?
What's in here?
Is this my suitcase?
Do I go under?
Do I go around?
He's dead?
No he's not!
Guys I think this is Metal Gear Solid!
Uh-oh!
I think I got tricked into playing...
Guys!
Uh-oh.
Again?
I didn't do this.
I didn't know.
Has there ever been stealth in Indiana?
Well there has been stealth in Indiana Jones.
Can I go through here?
How do I get around?
Do I go up?
I go up.
Find a spot to attach your whip.
I guess there.
Climbing?
Nice.
And up!
Over?
I hear someone whistling.
Ok, and up.
He is an in-game mechanic from Wolfenstein.
What items am I picking up?
Is there something to pick up?
Oh maybe that.
Ok.
Maybe I can throw it?
Oh yeah, LT.
I guess I want to go that way so...
Hold on!
No!
Oh my God.
He's got a stick.
I got my fist.
No!
He's got a shovel!
Why?
Who needs stealth?
This isn't a stealth game.
Who needs stealth anyway?
Why?
God!
Oh shit!
I can be a real murderer.
Nice!
He's not bleeding.
It's the glass that broke, you guys.
Don't worry about it, ok?
Boop!
The Vatican is concerned about the Pope's deteriorating physical condition.
That's what they were talking about.
Is this the end of an era?
Reports about the Supreme Pontiff's grave illness has sent tremors of uncertainty through the Holy See.
Raising questions about the future of the church and its position as a moral authority for millions of people around the world.
The vague statements coming from the Holy See have led to rampant speculations about the nature of the Pope's illness.
What do I want for my weapon?
We have so many options.
Opens from the other side.
Did that guy wake up?
No way.
What's this?
Oh, bandage.
I'll take that.
Hell yeah.
You think they stay down?
I really can't tell.
Here you are playing a stealth game now.
I didn't know.
I didn't know this would happen to me.
It's fine.
I'm really good.
Oh, I'm actually about to die.
I need some bandages.
Wait, how do I... Oh, it was up, down.
And use?
What was use again?
Shoot.
What did I just do?
No, not the apple.
RT.
Oh, thank you guys.
Okay.
Walk slowly backwards off ledges to grab them.
Slow.
Where is
my...
There it is.
My weapon.
Keep the music on to avoid suspicion.
We got a map.
Let's go.
Nice.
Yes, it will.
And this.
Opens the rampart gate in the southwest bastion of Castel Sant'Angelo.
Nice.
Chapel of the Condemned.
They wouldn't fight me in a church, right?
It is dusty in here.
Holy.
Caruso's letter.
The man in black has ordered us to let the black shirts into Castel Sant'Angelo.
For now I advise you to return to the Vatican.
My hands are tied, at least until the Pope has returned.
I suspect he would be awfully vexed by all this.
Nothing here.
A bird took a crap on his shoe.
Am I going the right way?
Let's see.
We are... supposed to get to... there?
I'm guessing?
Wait, am I right?
Get to the inner courtyard.
Oh yeah, we are so close.
Perfect.
Oh, it just saved for me.
Okay, nice.
Nothing here.
Press B to crouch.
Press RT to quietly knock out enemies with melee weapons.
Okay, I will do that.
Nice.
That guy is going to come back, isn't he?
Okay, no, he is down there.
Okay, what is this?
Alright, we got another weapon.
We got him right in between the crotch.
What is this one?
What is over here?
There is like little dots.
Requires a black shirt key.
There is like some little dots in the bottom right.
I'm covering them, but I'm not quite sure what they mean.
Okay, they didn't notice me.
Okay.
Okay, the other guy disappeared.
Can I crawl under here?
No.
That kind of sucks.
Oh god.
Oh, weapon durability.
I see.
I see, I see.
It's a weapon health.
Okay, that makes sense.
Thank you guys.
I wonder...
Maybe I should...
If I drop this, do you think he will hear it?
Yeah, I'm thinking I need to distract him and then get his butt.
Oh?
Or?
Throw it?
Wait.
Whip?
My whip?
Why am I not standing up?
There we go.
Can I whip it?
Whip it good.
Oh.
Oh shit!
Oh, bless you.
I think I need to stand up there and get it.
Okay.
Let's...
Hold on.
Alright.
Let's do this.
Leave me alone!
Oh, he left.
He straight up left.
Let's go.
Come on!
Arby!
And...
I'm doing something.
I'm spinning.
Guys, help me.
I'm really dizzy.
Indiana Jones, what am I doing?
Indy!
I'm about to run out of stamina.
There we go.
I'm trying to swing.
Swing across.
You guys!
Lower more.
You think that guy down there is going to notice me?
How do I lower myself?
Now that I've raised myself, you gotta be lower.
You guys, I don't know how to go down.
No.
Okay, good.
He's leaving.
B?
Oh, there's fall damage!
No!
No way.
Okay.
Oh, Arby.
Okay, climb up.
Oh, sorry.
Bless you.
Please!
Okay, hold on.
Let's go up a little more.
There we go.
And...
Jump!
Nothing.
It was nothing.
What?
You guys, I don't know if I'm cut out to be...
I don't know if I'm cut out for this lifestyle.
Where the hell did that other guy come from that was up here?
Where did that guy come from?
I don't know.
Wait, is he coming right now?
No, no, no.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
I'm running.
That sounds weird.
No, it doesn't.
There's nothing weird here.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
We're fine.
I think I need that key in there though.
Is this horror?
Okay.
Let's go see if anybody is around.
Nice.
Oh my god.
So I'm guessing the little thing above them is how much they notice you.
I'm assuming.
Okay, I think he just went back upstairs.
Oh, uh...
You got a book?
Oh, punch out?
Wait, I can punch him out?
Oh, it's a book called punch out.
Wait.
Restore stamina when the enemy is knocked out.
Yeah.
Sounds good to me.
Bandage?
I'll take that too.
And I'm gonna use it right now.
And I'm gonna take the key.
Guard house key.
Okay.
And what is this?
Money?
Oh, I'm robbing them too?
This is awesome.
Wait, a fly swatter.
Let's see.
What is this?
Oh, there's so many weapons we can use.
Okay.
Guard house.
I see you.
Where are we trying to go?
Wait.
Reach the top of the castello.
Okay.
Something else is back there?
I don't think so.
We have my shovel from before.
Oh, what's this?
Oh, document.
Thank you, actually.
You're right.
Valeria's letter.
Officer Acardo.
Against my will, Father Ventura has requested that I perform an inventory of the Vatican supply of medicine and send it to you.
In total, there are 304 small bottles of medicine and 157 large bottles.
Frankly, I do not understand why you would need to know this, but it is not my place to question, Father Ventura.
From the Vatican Pharmacy.
Maybe I should take my shovel.
And maybe we can get that guy.
I wish I could tell...
This game needs...
Like a...
Way to peek around corners.
Or...
Oh my god, bless you.
I did get a skill point.
I noticed that, but...
How do I... I don't know.
I haven't received that tutorial yet.
On how to use it.
Yeah, or a radar.
Exactly.
You can actually hold LT.
Oh.
And then click left or right stick.
You can peek.
It showed you how to use it.
It did?
Hold LT and then one of the sticks.
Maybe when I don't have a weapon?
Oh.
Oh my god.
Click the sticks.
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
Hold on, let's practice right here.
So I... Hold LT.
I see, I see, I see.
I like hear someone walking and it's freaking me out.
Oh, he's like right here.
I think.
Okay, he's left.
Back into the fray.
Back into the everything.
Alright, there's a guy.
I think he comes down here.
Okay.
Bless you.
I mean not bless you.
Where?
I don't want to be Indiana Jones anymore.
I want to be Dr. Brody.
Oh, there he is.
Do you think they will be able to see me when I peek?
Oh, it's okay.
We got his ass though.
Yippee!
We got him.
Let's go.
Yes.
This thing is pretty flimsy.
Oh my god, there's another guy.
Holy shit.
I'm running into here.
Use the guard house key.
Use it.
Use it please.
Nice.
Bless you.
Anyone in here?
What's this?
Open.
Money.
Revolver bullets.
Okay, check that.
What else?
Biscotti.
80 euros.
Press this to equip the revolver.
I have a revolver?
Since when?
And I have food.
Eat bread and boost health.
Nice.
Danny DeVito's letter.
The priests have been ordered to be obedient, so keep your gun holstered and behave.
If they give you any troubles, talk to Father Ventura.
He is on our side.
Mr. Danny DeVito.
Danny DeVito.
There's so much to this game.
It's kind of crazy.
I got a broom.
And I'm not afraid to use it.
I have a statue.
Why did I pick this up?
Excuse me?
The guard house key.
Oh my god, there's so many guys around.
I'm so scared of this place.
I don't even know where the hell I am.
Okay, we gotta go.
Okay, I think I'm heading... Wait, no.
I need to go...
Am I going to the little yellow dot or the big triangle dot?
You just went backwards through a shortcut.
Oh damn.
Okay, let's go back upstairs then.
Grab my rake.
That's a diamond, Minto.
You're right.
I look at one point.
The circle first?
Okay.
Which maybe we're headed to.
Where does he go to though?
You think he comes over here?
That was close.
Good job, guys.
Oh.
There you go.
Nice.
Anyway.
Wow, thanks for dropping a new weapon for me.
Nice.
Am I going this way?
Oh, sorry.
Wrong thing.
Oh, the yellow dot!
How do we get up?
Okay, hold on.
Climb!
Climb, climb, climb!
We made it!
Maybe I am meant to be this... Is that other guy still down there?
Yeah.
Oh, wrong button.
Wrong button.
Upsy-daisy.
It's a lot of controls to remember.
But I'll get the hang of it.
Eventually, probably.
Probably.
Eventually.
Okay, it's saved!
Wow!
Nice view indeed, Indy.
Wow, look at that.
Okay, I'm entering.
Breaking and entering, I think.
Am I in the right location?
Where am I?
We have to go all the way over there!
Okay.
Alright, guys.
No biggie.
Pretty light.
If I need to use my fists, I have them.
Oh, what's here?
How much money is that?
Did I hear somebody?
The Vatican.
Guitar?
Where?
Oh, there it is.
They are partying.
Wait!
This game is kind of awesome.
What if I just use my heels?
And we go and swing it, baby.
What?
Why is the location... Why is it getting further and further away?
Okay, no problem.
Yeah, I got this.
It's easy, probably.
Take their bread.
Let them go hungry.
I can go out that way.
If I go up, what's in here?
More bottles.
Lots of bottles around.
Oh, hold LT to press.
Oh, okay, that's lean.
Thank you.
What's through here?
Oh, shoot.
Courtyard of the Angel.
I saw the guy.
Gotta take their apple.
Bless you.
And I'm gonna use this.
Nice.
You think he'll turn around?
What did you hear?
Oh yeah, that's... Nevermind.
Yeah, nevermind indeed.
Oh my god, he has a dog!
Oh, shit.
Anyway...
Oh god, the dog.
What's this?
Oh, another thing.
Okay.
Let's go up.
Bless you.
We're one-hitting these guys now?
I think I'm going the right way.
Yeah, it's right over there.
I... avoid this guy.
Oh, there we go.
Sweet dreams, fella.
And... Oh, I got a lucky hat.
And a new weapon.
We're so good at this, you guys.
Wow, lots of bandages.
Yeah, we... Oh, and...
Captain's key.
That sounds important.
Glad we got that.
Oh no.
Wait, do I... Maybe.
Okay, hold on.
I have an idea.
What is this?
Let's... Okay, here's how we distract.
Maybe.
I... Oh, I'm scared, you guys.
I'm scared I'm gonna miss!
Gun on the gun rack.
What did you... What gun on the gun rack?
What gun on the gun rack?
Bless you.
On the ground?
On the wall?
Where'd he go?
Bless you.
It's gonna... Maybe get it from...
Not his booties.
Don't kill the dog.
The dog will kill me.
It's a doggy dog world.
Oh my god.
I think I have to go like this.
Is there a way to go around?
Like this?
Watch this.
We're gonna get this guy, don't worry.
We got him.
Don't worry about it.
Oh my god, he almost noticed me.
What the hell?
Is he coming?
He's not coming, right?
There's lots of... Oh my gosh, there's so much stuff in this game.
It just turned out to be a little slice of heaven.
Today we are going to the Great Pyramids.
Wish you were here.
What's it look like?
Wow.
I'm taking like even their just like... I got a donut.
Like their personal items.
Nothing is sacred for me.
My sticky fingers.
What's this?
Let's go.
Bless you.
Everybody sneeze in here.
I think those are bandages.
I might be wrong.
I was wrong.
Okay, let's try and go downstairs.
I don't know how to sneak past this guy, but we'll try.
Okay, there's the guy with the dog.
With the rifle.
I think... I fear I must have to throw an item and then somehow sneak past.
Maybe that wasn't far enough.
Is he gonna go?
No, why?
Why here?
I hate my afterlife.
Oh my god.
I'm sorry.
Whip crack.
Whip, whip.
That guy did not notice.
Okay, cool.
Let's go.
Unlock!
Oh shoot.
Oh shit.
What just happened?
That was such a silly dream now, wasn't it guys?
Wasn't that like a crazy dream that happened just now?
Whoa.
It's like I jumped out a window and died or something.
In my dream.
This game does dream sequences too.
Yeah, it's craziness.
It's so... Bless you.
It's so crazy.
That guy sounded close.
We're going... Yeah.
I was going the correct way.
I just have to find a way past these guys.
It's his fault.
It's this guy's fault.
Because... What the hell?
I threw the bottle or I threw the thing that way and then he comes towards me.
Use the rifle?
We're gonna awaken everybody in town.
Throw the rifle.
Maybe... Maybe like now.
Maybe if I hide here... Actually, does he go pretty far?
I don't know.
Note.
You left the key.
Ok.
That's fine.
Alright.
Now go.
Ok.
We did it.
We did it guys.
Easy.
Item limit reached?
What do you mean by that?
I'm too good at this game.
I lost my bottle.
Where are we?
Ok.
We're going...
Somewhere.
Game?
Give me a... Game?
Game, it disappeared off the map.
To loot goblin.
No.
Oh, right here.
I believe.
And also, some donuts.
They love donuts, don't they?
It seems.
That's where I tried to go and I failed miserably.
Ok, Andy.
Let's use our inside voice.
This is where I need to be.
I think.
Like right in front.
Right here.
Right here?
Right around here.
Yeah, I did kind of dive off on the side, but it was way cooler, wasn't it?
It's actually pretty...
Now I got to go find another weapon.
There we go.
Imagine getting whipped and then bonked in the head.
Couldn't be mean.
How embarrassing.
I think I saw that guy.
Ok.
Oh, we'll change that.
We'll change that, buddy.
Oh
God!
Oh!
We're fine.
He was possessed.
Anyway.
Let's use this real quick.
And then we'll grab a new one.
Bandage time.
Yeah, baby.
And grab a new one.
And what's this?
Oh, I'll turn my frying pan into a drying pan.
Who needs to carry bodies when you've got skills as good as mine?
Brawler!
Is it the... Oh, books!
Wait.
Oh, I see.
So this is how I am... Wait, so I don't need the money.
I don't need to unlock it.
It just automatically does it for me.
It seems.
So that's kind of nice.
Anyway.
Over this way.
Anything else in here?
Nope.
I can't really tell how it works.
Can't really tell.
Oh, is that our guy?
Get to Antonio.
Are you Antonio?
Are you my friend?
No.
No, you are not my friend.
You're just a guy?
You're just a guy standing there?
Really?
He literally closed his eyes and said, I do not see.
This game is so awesome.
I can't.
Oh, Antonio!
Yes!
Oh my gosh Antonio, you don't know.
Why couldn't you give me a different entrance to come in?
Huh man?
You don't know what I've been through to get here.
Oh my god.
I just saw Father Ventura with a black shirt on his way to the Castello.
Father Ventura?
What's that?
I said, who is Father Ventura?
He's got his AirPods in.
A man in black.
A friend of Mussolini.
Practically runs the Vatican now that the Pope has taken ill.
Oh no.
We know Father Ventura.
Indy, we read the notes.
If the winds are favorable.
Oh my god.
Shameless.
I'm following you Father.
Antonio.
Thanks Antonio.
I'm running through.
Are you coming with?
Okay.
Good guy.
Alright.
Fascista.
Ah.
Hey Antonio.
I might be Indiana Jones.
I was going to say.
I could use a new shirt.
Good gift for him.
Oh my god.
So cute.
Nice sink.
Grazie.
Yeah, I stole a lot of donuts though.
Maybe that's why I don't have much stamina anymore.
I keep taking donuts on my journeys.
I don't
know.
Look at him go.
They are crazy.
Crazy.
Break it down in the name of the lord.
Is it because of me?
They know I'm here.
Confetti?
Oh, Cornetti.
Sorry.
Father Antonio.
You are so cute.
Oh no, my item...
Here, hold on.
Let's eat some food.
Yeah, he is super tall.
Like a giant.
How short are we?
Oh.
Hello sister.
She does not see.
Damn it.
There you go.
I got a garage.
Why did he want a cat?
Why would the Vatican want a cat mummy?
Yeah.
I think Indy would eat a pita.
Only giants?
We are really just calling this guy a giant.
What?
Who wouldn't want one?
Okay.
Oh yeah?
Oh nice.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
My disguise robes.
Oh yeah!
Wait.
What do they look like?
Press to open the satchel and select your disguise?
Shut up!
What do I look like?
Please, I need to know.
I need a mirror.
Father Ford.
Let me see.
Oh, it just looks like a suit.
It does look very fancy.
Oh Padre Ventura!
Record scratch.
You're here to help Antonio.
He's going deaf, he says.
An old war wound, I'm told.
I'm just here to serve God.
Aren't we all?
Sorry that chat.
You guys have become Indiana Jones.
You guys are on his face.
Ooh.
Yeah, Ventura.
Get out of here.
Disapproving exhale.
Mortis.
What I am about to do has not been approved by the Vatican.
Good luck, Indy.
If you need me, I will be here, in my office.
OK, thanks Antonio.
I'm going to go snoop around the library.
Why?
I'm not going to take his record.
I'll see you later.
A superior recording.
OK, what's in your closet?
Anything else?
No?
OK.
Boop, boop, boop, boop.
Boop, boop, boop.
Hello sister.
Oh.
Grandma.
Why is yours red?
What's my next objective?
Circle.
Mystery thing.
Red is cardinals.
Like the bird?
Oh yeah.
Gosh.
I'm real tired from doing...
Fatherly duties.
Oh no.
Who are you?
What?
What's going on?
Who's moaning?
Wow, purple.
Donation box.
It's locked.
If we punch it, we might be able to get the money out.
Requires clerical key.
OK.
Alright, so that door was our thing that we wanted.
Vatican.
Yes, I'm supposed to be in here.
What is that?
Oh, the giant's pendant fits in there!
I've started calling him the giant now too.
God dammit.
This guy.
He's like, it's all my fault.
I was born big.
Oh god!
You scared me Antonio!
I thought...
I thought you were one of the other guys.
Oh my god.
Explore the secret passage.
Oh, it's dark, dark.
Antonio, could I have a light?
This will do.
Let's go.
Oh wait, this will do.
Alright Antonio, by candlelight we go.
Did you... You sounded like you didn't know about this part of the library though.
You look fine.
His mouth is moving.
My hands are shaking and my mouth is moving.
Raise the flame to see better.
Father Antonio, I think you are a liar.
Are you okay?
I love when game AI breaks.
It's my favorite thing ever.
Welcome to Mambo Ship, son of a bitch.
Watch your step Antonio!
Antonio, watch your step!
No, don't turn around.
Below the library.
Spookiness here.
It's all spookiness here.
This single candle is so powerful.
Holy cow.
My hands are shaking.
Smile emoji.
You good?
I'm glad we have him as company though.
This is kind of fun.
My game is saving and I don't know why.
There is so much stuff down here.
Watch your head.
Where are you going?
To figure out how to open up the gate, Antonio!
I'm not dumb here, okay?
Just a little bit.
I'm just a little stupid, okay?
Oh my gosh.
I like how we still have our whip on our side.
Minty sapling!
Welcome to Mambo Ship.
Thank you!
How do we open it?
I don't see... There is no like prompts.
Anything inside?
We swim?
Oh god.
There goes my candle.
A to ascend, B to descend.
And how do I go forward?
Just normal.
That's not so bad.
Oh my god.
I'm ascending!
No!
My candle!
I think I messed up you guys.
Can I have your candle sir?
My candle is at the bottom of the ocean.
Shut up Antonio!
Yeah, I knew that.
I'm thinking about my candle.
I think I need to go back for it.
Press L to swim faster.
Where did it go?
It disappeared.
Oh my god!
It sank and literally went to the bottom of the ocean.
Ok.
Here we go.
Blind me though.
Orbit.
Yike!
Oh thank you Antonio.
I don't have it anymore.
Laboratory.
A curious hand carved stone object of prehistoric origins?
What?
Are you...Oh this guy!
Oh my god!
Holy shit!
There is multiple rats on him.
It's freaky.
Who is this poor individual?
I don't know who you are talking about Antonio.
You just start...I'm just gonna start levitating.
From what you are writing.
Oh.
Mad scribbles.
What day?
Year?
1578 perhaps.
Time evaporates here.
I follow the signs to this accursed place.
At what cost Father Chris...Cresenjo...Zo...
Yeah.
What's in a new is this poor individual.
I do not.
Lost?
I am lost.
There is no escape.
My mind, rotting.
Unreadable scribbles.
I conserve fuel lest the darkness consumes me.
No!
I must exercise this miasma of despair.
Unreadable scribbles.
Whatever soul finds this.
Use the map.
Find the abominable etchings.
What do they herald?
Perchance it is all for naught.
Inkwell runs dry.
Heavenly Father save me!
I'll take the map.
It's a map.
Cresenjo's map.
You can bring me some photographic evidence of these inscriptions.
We can study them together in my office without raising suspicion.
Let's say I bring you some evidence.
You got a camera I can use?
No, but speak to Ernesto, the old janitor in the Vatican post office.
I hear he has some special deals from the lost and found section.
That doesn't seem...
Here is a very special key.
It will give you access to places in the Vatican only the priests are allowed.
It's the clerical key.
Thank you.
We're just gonna...
Okay.
Yeah, we're gonna prepare something for this guy.
Cool.
Nice.
You're not gonna go up?
Okay.
Alright, we're going up together.
Come on, buddy.
Antonio?
Oh, you're really slow, Antonio.
Come on, catch up.
Keep up, buddy.
Alright.
Okey-dokey.
He's old.
Yeah, but like...
It's pretty bad if you can't go up a few steps.
Oh my god, Antonio.
Oh my god!
Thank you, Antonio.
You sidestepping?
This guy looks lost.
I think
he's fine.
Probably.
Okay.
There's a door up there as well.
Okay, hold on.
Let's check out some of these places.
Oh, sister.
I got it so easily.
There you go.
She won't even look at me.
Oh, what's this?
A Vatican briscola club.
You are invited to join us for brotherly games of briscola.
All skill levels are welcome.
Gambling will not be tolerated.
Does the key work on this?
No, dang it.
No gambling?
Okay, so we got this unlocked.
Before that, hold on.
Do you think they'll tell me no running?
Wow, my stamina really got better.
Is it because of the fruit?
The donuts?
She's like, why are you heavy breathing?
Oh, see, yeah.
This also requires the key.
And then, I can't go through here.
I will get that donation box up, I swear.
Donuts make him go nuts.
Oops.
I did the wrong thing.
There we go.
Nice.
What are you doing?
Fixing that light?
How many monkeys does it take to screw in a light bulb?
Come on, lady.
You got it.
Okay.
And then, this is where we came from.
Yep, okay.
Cool.
I guess we didn't need to...
So, we're going to the post office.
Which is...
Where's my map?
I don't have one.
That's fine.
We'll figure it out.
We're smart.
Nice painting.
They're very nice paintings.
It's art, YouTube.
It's art.
Look at that.
YouTube, it's art.
That's a lot of cans.
Nice.
I was just talking about needing a map.
And there we go.
We're going that way.
The Vatican post office.
Buongiorno.
Hello.
What's wrong with your face?
What's wrong with your face, sir?
Buongiorno.
She looks possessed.
You wouldn't hurt the father, would you?
Who's taking your money?
Don't worry about it.
The theft report?
Oh shit, that's me.
It's just his acne.
Oh no.
Caught the kid stealing confiscated artifacts from the dig site.
The boy is from England.
Oh no.
Says he's here with that confused professor Ventura.
Wait, says he's here with that confused professor Ventura kicked out from...
Oh, the professor Ventura kicked out from the dig site.
Locked him in the holding cell until we can figure out what to do with him.
Is that going to be our...
Ah!
What are you going to do?
I'm safe here.
Guys,
I think I need to restart.
I think...
Use your gun.
There is like one on every person.
It took me...
I won't do it again.
I promise.
I'm a changed man.
That guy came out of nowhere, I swear.
Who was it?
Hi.
Oh god, he's possessed too.
There is something not right with this city.
I'm a changed man, I promise.
They won't get mad at me for just looking around though, right?
Mystery note.
A ticket stub.
Discounted price for members of the military and kids.
52.
OK.
What's in here?
Oh!
I'm just...
I'm just a guy.
52, but part of it was taken off, you know.
Bonjourno!
Signposts allow you to quickly travel back to locations.
Oh!
Greetment.
Greet.
I'm changed.
Hello!
Are you the signpost, Matt?
Do I need to talk to you?
The numbers on the front and the back, you think?
I was thinking that.
But I'm also so scared of getting caught.
See, look, they see.
They see me.
Let's see.
What was that?
What was on there?
Oh, wrong button.
It was...
52, 38 or 39?
There's a little eye that appears next to you when you're visible.
Oh, I did notice that.
OK, I see.
So if I steal now...
What was it?
52...
38, unless it's the opposite way.
Nice.
Bonjourno!
Anyway...
You have unused adventure points.
Wait, what?
How do I use it?
Then RB...
In my books.
Adventure points.
Unlock new things.
But how do I use it?
How do I unlock it?
I'm so confused.
Press right one more time?
Not that, no.
It's the book, right?
But it like shows things that I've...
Press on the D-pad.
Oh, hello.
No!
I didn't mean to!
No, please!
Oh my God.
I was in my bed!
Hello.
I'm just chilling here.
We're really sneaky.
OK, anyway...
I'm gonna stand over here.
And we're gonna open my book.
And I'm gonna press RB.
And not have a gun.
I can't believe...
OK.
Alright, lucky hat.
I have 350 points.
After being knocked out, Indy can pick up his fedora using X, giving him a second chance at the fight.
Lucky hat is disabled while Indy is...
What?
Why are you...
Why were you sneaking up on me like that?
What other books you got?
That's what we're gonna see.
We got brawling books.
Punch out.
Restore stamina when an enemy is knocked out.
Deal increased damage in armed and hand-to-hand melee combat.
That one looks good.
That one seems good, I think.
Um...
Uh... I have to close it.
And then reopen it.
That's kind of weird.
Combat.
The last hit before an improvised weapon break deals additional damage.
Yeah, the other one was just 25.
I feel like we could do the two...
Oh, that's not what I meant to do.
I feel like we could do...
I brought friends.
Everybody...
I'm so sorry.
I thought I opened up.
Buongiorno!
I did not say that very well, did I?
Bless you.
What?
I can't.
I'm destined to get my ass kicked in this fucking city.
Oh god, help me!
God!
The eye!
It wasn't there!
I promise you!
I promise you it wasn't there!
It wasn't there!
I am mad of god!
I'm leaving.
You know what?
I don't care about the other amount.
Okay.
This button.
Wait, no.
Okay, brawling.
We're gonna unlock this ability.
Okay, and we're gonna unlock this ability.
Nice.
Close.
Where are we going?
We're going to the post office.
Which is that way.
Let's go.
Now you're a man with god.
Oh, it's saving!
Thank goodness.
Steal medicine bottle.
No.
I'm not gonna steal any money.
Hello, sir.
Yes, move along, father.
Okay.
Bless you.
Everybody is sneezing here.
I think there is an epidemic here.
What are you doing?
I think you need more...
How do you do?
What am I reaching for?
The flame?
I'm like...
Christmas decorations.
That's a big axe.
Bless you.
A lot of guitars.
Yeah, there is a lot of guitars lying around.
What's in here?
Yeah, okay.
Nevermind.
I'm getting out of here.
So true.
Okay, nevermind.
I'm gonna go investigate this tent.
Just kidding.
There is a guy standing right there.
Okay.
No, he's not.
Is he?
The guy is over there.
We are out of here.
Where?
Oh, right here.
What's going on?
I need to send my mail.
Why is that lady so close to the wall?
She looks like a ghost.
Answer the question.
Why is she so close?
Where is he going?
Okay.
There is an incident.
What is she doing?
Okay, I'll check out this way.
Medicine bottle.
Remedy for all.
Oh, nice.
And bread?
Oh, I can't have it.
You think they're gonna notice if I jump up here?
Let's try the other way first.
You think she's going ghost?
What do I do?
You could try, Andy.
Oh my god, she's still there.
The holy ghost.
I guess we could go up here.
Nobody sees us.
Here we go.
Father, grant me the strength to be sneaky up the wall and have nobody notice me.
Thank you.
Buongiorno.
You have entered a restricted area.
Your disguise will not keep you safe.
Stay low to avoid detection.
Are you serious?
Climbing Ace.
No, my disguise!
There sure are a lot of guys around there.
Maybe I should have gone the other way.
What is this book anyway?
Let's check it out.
Climbing Ace.
Drains less stamina, enables faster movement by using L while ledge climbing.
Here I go.
That guy doesn't notice me, right?
Oh.
Hey!
Chill out!
Yeah,
dummy.
Where are you going?
Uh...
Okay, I'll just, um... Let's just fight him with my fists.
And let's hide his body before the guys come back.
Please pick up the body.
Okay.
Before those guys...
Oh, uh...
You know what?
Let's just leave it right here.
How do I drop him?
Nice.
Uh...
Okay.
Where'd the dog go?
Is there anything here?
Oh, a bottle.
I don't see it.
Like, eyes.
I don't see them.
Do you?
Oh, there they are.
Okay.
The dog leaves?
Are those three guys or two?
Oh, it's four guys.
Oh my God.
Could've been five guys.
I thought... I can't tell if the very far back guy is a poster.
No, he's moving.
He's definitely a real guy.
It could've been five guys!
Uh...
Do you think they'll notice if I...
Let's just do that.
Where am I?
Oh!
Requires cellar key!
Dang it.
What is the exclamation point?
Okay.
Okay, I'm gonna throw it.
I'm gonna throw it nice and far.
Oh, that's not far.
Uh...
Wait.
No, I'm trying to...
LT... Oh my gosh, my stamina.
Indy, please.
Chill out.
I was just trying to...
I was trying to look... You know how you LT and then you can look.
Oh gosh.
They're both there.
I'm gonna go back.
And I'm gonna grab the bread.
What if I go around the other way, actually?
There was the other way.
You know what?
I don't have to go this way.
Time to eat some bread.
Bread.
Wait.
Eat it?
No, don't throw it.
Eat it.
There we go.
And grab new bread.
Cornetto eaten.
I'm getting achievements for this.
What if I like, rob them of their uniforms, you know?
And just walk around?
You think I should change?
Nice achievement.
I don't see any other better weapons, unfortunately.
Oh, but we can grab a glass.
Guys, I don't know which way is better.
Honestly, I have no idea.
Which way is the better way to go?
What?
Even the painter got me.
Even the...
Even the normie guy...
The normie guy got me.
Oh my gosh.
There's so many people walking by.
They won't notice the bodies.
Why are there so many guys walking by?
Why?
Good thing guns weren't invented yet.
So true.
Time to eat...
An apple.
Orange.
And I'm gonna eat the whole lemon.
Oh, so apples and oranges and stuff replenish that stamina.
Okay, interesting.
Okay, we're gonna throw it nice and far.
All the way over there.
Throw, Indy!
I can't... Oh my gosh, Indy.
You're... Indy, you're too thick.
No, Indy.
Indy.
Indy, I need you to... Indy.
Indy, I need you to sneak through here.
They won't notice me, right?
Let's just keep walking.
And go up the stairs.
In here.
Clerical key.
And... Unlock.
Unlock.
And... Oh, shit, shit, shit, shit.
And inside.
And we're good.
Nice.
Catherine's letter.
How?
Don't worry about it, okay?
Where is that delivery boy you promised?
I have been waiting in the Sistine Chapel for well over an hour.
You know how eager I am to learn more about the mad priest, Crescenzo.
Which makes me wonder, are you withholding something from me?
You're holding out on me.
I will stay here for a little while longer.
So unless the delivery boy has stumbled and broken his ankle, I expect him to be here forthwith.
I'm not the only one interested in Crescenzo.
Crescenzo.
New fieldwork.
Alright, so the mad priest.
Alright, so we're finding Sister Catherine.
I'm keeping this safe.
Am I... It says exclamation point, but like, shouldn't I be fine in here?
You know, like...
Is there something?
Oh, requires camera.
I need the camera!
What do we have here?
Yes, sir.
Ernesto!
Why?
Okay, Indy.
So creepy.
He's just Indy.
Some people just love the sound of their own voice.
So he can understand Italian, but can't speak it?
A camera?
Does he want my money?
It's a good thing I've been stealing from everybody.
Antonio is a lousy bum who cheats at cards.
Antonio!
You are a cheater!
A camera obscura.
Wow.
Oh, mamma mia.
How much?
I've been stealing a lot from the guards.
As long as it's not like 500 euros, I'll be fine, right?
How much?
Tell me the price!
Do you think it depends on how much money?
Wow!
Do you think that they make it an amount based on how much you actually have?
How much do I have?
Oh, I have 600!
Give me the money.
I mean give me the camera.
Damn.
Expensive.
The camera is yours.
And tell Antonio that I still think he is a lousy cheat.
What is this?
Not enough.
Wait, I have to buy this too?
Adventure books.
I'm good for now.
Alright, let's take a look.
Informative guide to discovering the mysteries of the Vatican.
How much money is that?
Hold on!
L to view finder.
I only have so much.
Alright, cheese!
Am I in the frame?
You need to look down a little bit, man.
Oh my god!
Wow!
We got a two star in Ernesto!
Two star in Ernesto.
Just hold still.
Thank you!
You guys scared me.
How do I put this away?
How do I put it away?
Try B?
I still just have a bread out.
I'm not doing anything suspicious.
I dropped something.
So what are we doing now?
Photograph inscriptions.
Oh wow!
There's four of them.
Ok.
We are in an area that's not good.
Why are these guys fine?
These guys are fine, but not me?
So unfair.
Yeah, nice.
Recipe for disaster.
Risotto?
Do not touch.
Pick some fresh chanterelles in the forest.
Wow!
Lots of butter.
Ok.
You think this is legit?
You think this is real?
Like you could follow this?
Well, you'll have to go to the forest.
What are you doing, madam?
God, you scared me.
Ok.
Not in there.
Alright.
It's legit?
It's real?
Why are you peeping on whoever is the neighbor?
Are you saying I could have just gotten in through the window?
I guess that would have been easier.
Maybe I should leave through the window.
Cool.
That guy is still out.
Awesome.
Which means the guys over here are probably all still out.
And we need to go over this way.
I guess they just don't mind.
It's right in here.
Ok, nice.
Wait.
Is it?
On the other side?
Are we?
Yank.
Oh my gosh!
Wow!
That's so cool!
Let's eat some bread.
And then we'll take a donut.
I don't want to let it reach for everything.
Dang.
But we can already be up here.
I think we need to go up here.
Oh!
Why are we making that noise, Indy?
Hello, sir.
Do you mind if I photograph?
Is it?
Where is it?
Oh, I think I need to go to the other side.
Ok, hold on.
Let's do this side first.
Since, you know...
Is there a good way to...
Oh.
R.B.
Alright.
Easy.
Ok.
Hello, sir.
In here?
There is something here, though.
Moxie?
It requires talk to Valerie.
Ok.
Hello!
Don't worry about my ankles.
Oh no!
No!
Bastardo!
Cat!
Oh my god, cute!
Don't be mean!
I don't like her.
Yeah?
Oh, I did grab one.
I did, actually.
Bastardo.
Hey.
Moxie.
Oh, not Moxie.
Your name is...
Your name is Val...
I can't talk to her anymore.
It really wants me to get the Moxie.
Not enough medicine.
I see, I see.
So I don't talk to her.
I trade it for the books.
I see, I see, I see.
Need more Moxie.
Ok.
I guess we do go back inside the other area.
That's kind of nice, then.
I've heard... I saw this, you guys.
Look how cute!
I saw this as a thing.
Oh my god, this cat is so cute!
Indy, shut up.
You get adventurer points by photographing the cats.
Is that not the cutest thing ever?
This game is awesome.
Ok, up we go.
You get points for the cat.
Indy, hold off the donuts, my man.
Is there a good way to fall down this one?
Is there an easy way for me to not break my ankles again?
Uh oh, the crowd disappeared.
Oh, but the little exclamation point is not there anymore, so...
RB, I tried that last time.
Grapple down.
I did walk backwards before, though.
No whip, just walk backwards.
Drop.
Oops, I did the wrong thing.
That's right.
Walk away.
Ok, everything seems to be in this area, I think, so we should be good just walking around.
Hot dog, indeed.
I love a game where you can take checkies of Vatican cats.
What?
Are you telling me I did all that for nothing?
Are you telling me?
Oh my goodness, excuse me.
It's over here, right?
I'll go around, I'll go around.
Don't want to cause any disturbance here.
Oh my, where the hell did you come from?
This lady came from the walls?
This place is so cursed.
Ah, here we go, here we go.
This, right?
Or...
I feel like it must be this, right?
X.
I don't want the paintbrush.
Yeah.
I like how much detail are in these.
I don't even have the max settings on.
I bet the game looks so good.
With it, you know?
Okie dokie.
She was just standing there, don't worry about her.
This is a nice little garden, I like it.
Oh.
A cat.
I don't think I got points for it though.
No!
The cat!
Can I climb?
This is very important.
I want him yawning though, I want him yawning.
Yawn.
I missed my cat!
I missed my cats.
They're in the other room.
Is the camera lens...
Nice.
Goodness.
Ok, good.
Excuse me.
Ok.
Go back through.
Yeah.
Father.
Ok.
Like, ok.
Everything else is in here.
But we have to not get discovered by these guys over here that were sussing us out before.
Ok.
Alright.
Strange inscriptions.
Here?
I don't see any.
I'll take a picture anyway.
Oh wait, maybe down here?
This game looks so fun.
It is really fun.
Maybe it's on another part of the...
Oh, here, here, here, here.
I got it.
Different angle?
Oh my god, Indy.
You are so...
Ok, we got the second one.
Alright.
Over this side.
Oh, there's a question mark going on.
You're still alive?
You must really like Indy.
It's only been three hours?
Hasn't been that long.
Alexander, thank you so much for the 20 gift.
Thank you!
I saw a question mark up here.
Don't...
Oh my god.
No, no, no.
Don't even notice me.
Oh my god.
I think we're good.
Who is noticing me anyway?
Jeez.
She's nice.
Thank you!
Seven months.
Thank you.
Is it Senpai?
Oh my god.
Senpai noticed me.
Where is this one?
We're like right on top of...
Oh, up there?
Let's get that one last maybe.
There's also one over here.
How do we get to it?
It's like the other side of the building.
Okay, there's also...
Can I come up there?
Wow, this looks so great!
I'm gonna take a picture of it.
To celebrate.
This really awesome thing.
It looks really cool.
Where is it?
Is it over here that I have to climb?
But they're all looking at me.
Oh, they sometimes don't look at me.
Okay, I'm gonna do it.
Oh, I'm not gonna do it.
Once the icon goes away, I'm doing it.
I'm doing it!
I'm doing it.
Oh, right here.
There we go.
Nice.
I'm doing it.
Nobody is noticing me.
Probably.
I think.
Do they see me?
No?
Okay.
Where do I...?
Oh, they're right here.
Nobody is noticing me.
I'm too short.
Uppies!
Okay, there we go.
I'm doing it.
Oh.
Hello, sir.
Buongiorno.
Could you not stare at me while I parkour?
Yeah.
Who else is looking at me?
I have a little icon.
Okay.
How did I get over here?
That's so crazy.
Anyway.
Next one.
Let's get in there.
Take the picture.
Third inscription.
Got.
Back over this way.
Just average priest behavior.
Exactly.
You think I can take this guy out?
You think he'll care if I start hopping up everywhere though.
Hello.
Bored Sai.
So true.
I'll wait until he turns around.
Yeah.
You want a picture?
You want me to take a picture of you?
No?
Okay.
Yeah.
Wasn't there one over here?
Or am I crazy?
I suddenly feel like raiding some lost arks.
True.
Oh, yeah.
There's like...
supposed to be one...
up there?
Do I keep going?
Oh, I do keep going.
Okay.
Oh my god.
That was close.
There's people painting even.
Oh, this is a restricted place.
Oh gosh.
Okay.
It's...
right here though.
I'm secret.
Where is it?
We're in the courtyards.
Oh my gosh.
Where is it?
Oh, whoops.
My bad.
Somewhere.
Probably up?
Oh, that way.
I think.
You think they'll notice me?
You think they'll notice?
Take
the picture.
Bad angle!
Okay.
Alright.
Bad angle.
Return to Antonio?
That was it?
That was all I needed?
Nice.
What about the other ones?
Oh, interesting.
Okay, that's fun.
Professor Savage.
Is it him?
I think it's that guy down there.
Good thing this guy over here is blind.
I want to go say hi to him, but I don't think we can get down there.
Yeah, what were you thinking?
I don't know how to even get down there, you guys.
Ledge on the left.
What is this?
Oh, repair kit.
Interesting.
Oh, there's a lot of guys.
Oh, wow!
There's a lot of people.
Oh wait, I can be in here.
This isn't a bad area.
Look, because my thing isn't red.
So we can actually just kind of freely walk around here.
There's no exclamation point.
We are a free priest.
I think.
Hello.
I'm the priest.
Buongiorno.
And down.
Wait, how do I get out of here?
Papa?
Oh no.
Who will replace him?
Mr. Savage.
Hello.
I wonder if it's possible to like...
To skip this guy.
Oh, a fellow archaeologist.
We've heard about this guy.
Sydney!
He is very dapper.
No!
Breakthrough.
Yeah.
Absorum Angelorum.
I'm smarter than you, Professor Savage.
Lasagna.
I don't know.
Retrieved.
I love this guy.
Alright, alright, alright.
This guy has just been rambling all by himself down here.
Yeah, father.
And he is so...
He is so like... ominous sometimes.
To the library.
Ok.
Library.
Yeah, don't...
What's this?
A card.
Oh!
A fool.
I'll get you guy.
Don't worry.
I'll get you little man.
Your little apprentice.
Am I going the right way?
It's so...
It's so tiring being a priest.
Ok, we are going the right way.
A minto card?
Hey, hey, hey.
What do you mean by that?
Oh!
This is the fast travel!
That's so awesome!
Ok.
Do you think they'll think that's witchcraft?
Nope.
Ok, we're fine.
They mentioned it earlier, but I...
I wanna go in there.
I wanna steal.
I wanna do crimes.
Ok.
Oh, sorry.
It's not this door.
Oh!
There's so many more people.
Is that the Ventura guy?
Ok.
Alright, we can go.
Actually, let's go upstairs.
Let's go up the up way.
This lady is still working on this lamp.
Wait, it's gone now.
Ma'am?
Ma'am, the lightbulb.
Ma'am, the lightbulb is missing.
How mysterious.
What are you doing?
Alright, this guy is still listening to his record.
I'm here!
Crescenzos.
Yeah, I got it.
Take these.
How did we print these so fast?
Where are your magnifying glasses?
Alright, let's investigate.
I'm examining.
This looks terrible.
I need to be a better photographer.
1930's Polaroid.
Like a giant.
What about this one?
This also has a really big guy.
And the sword.
A warrior.
What about this one?
This guy is dead.
This one is...
Oh, treasure.
A giant man.
What do these inscriptions say?
It says...
Secret passage.
Oh!
Ok, Indy, let's use our indoor voice again.
Oh, geez!
Ok.
A demon?
Alright!
What the hell?
Oh, look, I'm looking.
I'm observing.
I'm examining.
I'm translating the Latin.
Excuse me?
Wait, that's real blood?
Or rum?
He whipped that out so, so, so excitedly.
Indy's got a little look in his eyes.
I will.
The camera icon is up.
Yeah, maybe we can take a photo of him and it gives us some points, alright?
Say cheese!
There must be more interesting things to take a picture of than this old priest, Indy.
You look great.
Maybe there is an explosive secret hidden below the tower.
I would be curious to hear about it.
Ok, I will go right now.
Rescue.
Oh, we have to rescue Sidney.
I will go eventually.
Take a picture of the giant.
Where?
Oh, it's right outside.
Ok, we just gotta keep going.
Adjusting painting.
You're therefore perfect, even as your father who is in heaven is perfect.
That's fine, you can take more photos and stuff.
Ok.
Rescue Sidney.
On our way, on our way.
I'm gonna rescue Sidney and think then I might be done for today.
How do I get in there?
Ok, sorry.
So sorry.
Ok, we gotta climb over.
Wait, but it's all like barbed wire.
Ok, we gotta find an area without barbed wire.
Or... No, I don't think... I was gonna say we could go from up here, but I don't think we can.
Oh, was this open before?
Ok, my turn.
Ok, just kidding.
Everything has a barbed wire you guys.
What's this way?
The way we are supposed to go apparently.
Wait.
Is this to Sidney?
I guess so.
Oh, oh.
Excuse you.
Captains can see through your disguises.
Ok.
What do you mean disguises?
Ok, we are going this way, right?
Ok.
Oh, I'm in a restricted area?
Ok, nevermind.
How do we want to go about this?
Nobody is noticing me?
Don't notice me?
Nobody is looking at me?
Everybody...
Let's go.
Let's take the long way.
The fountain of confession.
Sealed?
Oh, come on.
Let's go the even longer way?
The longest way?
We are going to go super duper long way?
We are going to go all the way?
Probably?
Ok.
Alright.
Here we go.
No confessions right now.
Wait.
Does it say what's wrong with it?
Why can't we get in?
Why can't we go?
Why?
The barbed wire.
That would be a good weapon to pick up, I think.
We are going to go the absolute super duper long way.
Nevermind.
We are going to go the longest way actually possible.
We are going to go the mega long way.
The mega LeDawn way.
What am I supposed to take a picture of?
These guys?
What am I supposed to be taking a picture of?
Oh, they noticed I'm here.
Oh wow, it's another thing.
New fieldwork.
Fifth inscription.
The secret of giants.
Maybe it wasn't them at all.
Is there any way I can climb up there?
I don't think so.
Okay,
we're gonna...
How do I get over there?
Is it because you're not getting fed?
That's why you're getting sick?
I don't really understand.
I'm just exploring at this point.
Oh...
Okay, I guess I'm allowed down here.
What's going on in here?
Oh boy.
What's this?
Yeah, what's going on?
Oh, new discovery.
Underground boxing!
Oh wait, don't tell me what it is.
We ruined the mystery.
I fit in?
What's that?
What is that?
Oh wait.
This is where we were just before.
This is where we were and we saw like the...
We fast traveled.
I think I'm allowed to sprint here.
The great circle.
We did it!
We went into the great circle!
One hand it's weird that this game is in FPS.
On the other hand, Indie kinda looks like my dad from 20 years ago.
That's also weird.
Why is the frame rate dropping all of a sudden?
Alrighty.
Alrighty, we're figuring out...
Oh, we're getting noticed?
Just kidding.
Oh god, he's about to notice me.
Let me in!
Let me in to the fight club!
Maybe I can get them one at a time here.
You got your fist up.
Come on!
Yeah, I'm right here!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Oh, how do I put my camera away?
Nice.
Oh, you're still up?
Will you let me into the fight club now?
I ate the bagel.
Does my suspicion ever go down?
No trace of an enemy.
Yeah, yeah, exactly, exactly.
Nothing here.
I'll just put you...
Right there.
Oh, I'm better now!
Okay, nice.
It does eventually...
It does eventually disappear.
Okay.
I can't believe the weather we're having today.
See?
That's how you escape.
You just go after one guy.
Guys, I really am not sure how to get up there.
Wait a second, they're all gone.
Oh, that's the captain right there.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna leave.
I'm gonna...
He
doesn't notice me though.
Can I get up?
There we go.
Is it suspicious if I jump up here?
Nope, apparently not.
I'm just, you know, a scaffolding priest.
Don't mind me.
I'm in a restricted area now.
But this is nothing to be alarmed about.
Oh god, my chat is broken.
It's okay.
Oh, and there's dogs and there's... Okay, we need to go like right here, I think.
And we'll go inside.
How are we gonna rescue this kid?
Okay, inside.
Nice.
This is the place, right?
No!
I went into the wrong wood?
Hmm.
Oh, it's that one over there.
Wow, there's a symbol on this door.
I wonder what it means.
Is there anything else we can take in here?
Take that.
I'm afraid to open this.
Let's go.
Sorry guys, my chat is broken and I can't read it.
Okay.
They turn around.
Oh my god.
Go, go, go.
Right here.
Oh shoot.
That's where I need to go.
Let's...
Let's... Can you pet the dog?
Huh?
You think there's gonna be enough... Oh, bless you.
You think the dog will notice me?
Probably, I imagine.
I'm scared.
Rush him?
Where's the guy and his dog?
Oh, right here.
There's the dog.
It's just a dog patrolling?
They even have the dogs patrolling?
Oh my god, he's staring right at me.
Nice doggy.
Yeah, that's right.
Good.
Oh, he even opened the door for me.
This is the room, right?
Come here.
Inside we go.
Guy didn't hear anything, right?
I'm trying to see if I can get something, you know.
Ok, let's just...
Oh shoot.
Oh no, no, no.
No, no, no.
No!
Hey, stop parrying!
Stop blocking, buddy!
Oh god.
We're fine.
Oh my god, this is so...
I think we got him.
Nice!
Yeah, Robin Blind!
Oh what?
This was here the whole time!
Oh shoot.
Ok,
they just don't stop coming, do they?
How many are up here?
I think I got everybody.
I think we're good.
Might as well just loot the place now, you know.
Hell yeah!
Think he's dead?
No!
I'm not a killer!
Postcard.
Oh no, I missed it!
Crucifixion of Saint Peter.
That's what it is.
Everybody?
Maybe I had to do this.
Maybe I couldn't go through the other way.
Maybe I couldn't go through the other way, because...
Maybe it's locked.
Let's go check it.
You know, it might be like... Oh, you can't go through here.
Yeah, see?
I had the right idea.
Don't leave them any food.
Or any entertainment.
Taking your playing cards.
Actually yeah, let's eat our apple-ies.
Nice, and...
Well, I can't take their bread, so...
Take that, take that, take that.
Nice.
Any of these open?
No.
OK, let's go get Sidney.
Sidney, I'm coming for you!
Whole lemons.
Indiana Jones is kind of wild for that.
Oh shit!
That's not Sidney.
I was like, wow, Sidney is a little bigger than I imagined.
Nevermind!
Is this guy insane?
Sidney!
Got the jail cell key.
Oh, let's heal.
Let's heal.
And I will heal.
Oh, you know what?
Grab that.
OK, nevermind.
I thought I was still in the menu.
I'm stupid.
Good job everybody!
Nice!
Yay!
Sidney is coming home!
Don't attack me, don't attack me, don't attack me.
Sidney!
Oh no, sir!
I'm so sorry, sir!
Aye, sir.
Sorry, sir.
Please, sir.
Can I have some more?
Yeah.
Oh, come on.
Giuseppe?
What happened to the frame rate?
I wouldn't say clear.
I don't think I took care of the outside.
Get to the excavation site.
Where the hell is that?
OK.
Oh, I see.
We go back through and then we go that way.
Which we will do next time.
We got a letter.
Sidney's letter.
No time.
Hold on.
I kind of want to maybe start the game not in here when we play next time.
So let's leave.
You know?
Novel idea.
Let's leave the premises and then we shall...
What is this?
And then we shall...
Start next week.
Wait.
Hello?
Why am I not using this?
Use?
Oh, my health is full.
I just realized.
Oh, I'm too good at this game.
What's down here?
What was that?
Take that.
Nice.
OK.
Full HP.
I could have done this the entire... Oh my god.
Wait a second.
Wait, this was always an option?
No.
No way.
Yeah, see?
We are going through the garden now.
And now we are not in a restricted zone.
Now we are...
Oh shoot.
I better stay away from here.
No!
Oh, is it because I have a weapon?
Oh shoot.
No.
Back to Fight Club.
Hey.
Let me in.
So the first rule of Fight Club is...
You show us the Fight Club signature fight dance.
Fight!
Are they coming for me?
I'll just chill here until...
Until they get tired I guess.
Nothing here.
Oh my god!
He just said nothing here!
This game is reading my... Oh shoot.
Nothing here.
No trace of an enemy, exactly.
This game!
This game is reading my mind!
I can't do this anymore.
This is fruitless, yeah.
This is fruit fly.
Actually, you are fruitless.
I took all of them.
I took all your fruit.
Oh, we are better now.
Nice.
Let's go.
It's actually a great location.
Oh, sorry, I couldn't... I can't read your super chats.
No!
Sorry guys.
Alright, anyway, I'm gonna drop this item.
And now I'm really not suspicious.
I'm Mr. No Suspicion Priest Guy.
The priest you'd never be suspicious of guy.
The least suspicious priest ever.
I like that it saves a lot actually.
It's pretty nice.
Okay, we just keep going.
Okay, Mr. Savage is gone too.
Awesome, awesome.
Good day.
May I enter?
How do you do?
Oh, okay.
Can I pet the dog?
I'm trying to pet the dog, please.
What if I sneak behind you?
Okay.
Alrighty guys, yeah.
We are gonna end it here.
I think this is a good spot.
Thank you guys for... I'm so sorry I'm PNG this whole stream.
Hopefully, maybe next time...
Maybe next time I can... I don't know, I think I'll have to be a PNG again.
But that's okay.
This has been a lot of fun.
I can't believe how...
How...
Almost Metal Gear this is.
But it's a good time.
I hope you guys are enjoying it too.
It definitely does feel like Indiana Jones, which...
Of course is the best.
So, yeah.
I will see you guys whenever I see you next.
And I can read chat, but like only through...
Only through...
What's it called?
OBS.
So, it's been a little scuffed.
Thank you for the super chat.
I can't read it.
It says real talk.
Oh gosh.
See, this is why I switched to my mouse.
And I can't go to... I can't... Let me just quit the game.
Bye game.
Can I leave the menu please?
Exit game.
Oh yeah, look.
This is really where I'm at.
That's so fun.
Exit game.
Okay.
We're good now.
Why is my chat always freezing?
One second.
I'll fix it.
I'll just be...
Big Minto now.
Thank you, Trine Princess!
Yeah, baby.
And I am going back to...
Live control room.
You make me spit out coffee.
No!
Don't spit out your coffee!
Make Minto bigger, please.
Here, actually.
Let me just do this.
There we go.
Thank you guys for the stream!
It was a lot of fun!
And I hope you're enjoying Indiana Jones!
How many murders?
21 murders, 5 deaths, 7 times cover blown so far.
That could be worse, you know?
But I'm having so much fun.
Even as a PNG, wiggle.
What did I just press?
I don't know.
Wiggle, wiggle, wiggle.
I'm
having fun!
I'll see you guys next time I see you!
Otsubito, thank you for the fun Indiana Jones stream!
You can really see the love for the franchise the devs have.
Also, Faith Mo...Faith movie?
Faith movie?
No way!
Oh my god, you guys are going to have to watch it together!
That's so awesome!
Thank you!
Love the indie brain rot.
Indie brain rot.
This has been a lot of fun.
I've been having so much fun.
You want to watch it with us?
Of course I do!
That's our game!
Bye PNG... Bye bye!
Bye bye!
I'll see you guys!
Otsubito!
Bye bye!
Itadakimasu!
Like you can see the whole thing.
OK bye!
My
hat, the whole stream.
I didn't get to use my hat the entire stream.
It belongs in a museum.
I came to say goodbye to you guys.
I came to say goodbye to you, the viewer.
Thanks for watching!
Bye bye!